el fuego parece ir cesando pero las
labores continúan llegando uno de los
lugares más afectados por los incendios
en francia los bomberos crean áreas de
contra fuego árboles talados y apilados
hacen parte de la estrategia para
limitar las llamas en caso de su
reactivación con usar de moldea nos
pidieron que hiciéramos son contra
fuegos entonces nuestros equipos tienen
motosierras y también hay empresas
civiles
empresas de alquiler que vienen y nos
ayudan
son métodos preventivos que buscan
evitar que se profundice la tragedia de
gijón donde cerca de 21 mil hectáreas
han sido encendidas si tus ideas y
acciones son iglesias también son
acciones que se llevan a cabo de manera
reflexiva con profesionales del bosque
para que puedan reutilizar
económicamente toda la madera que se
corta
en la población del año también girondo
las labores de los bomberos parecen
interminables allí otras son las
estrategias raspando el suelo del bosque
buscando grasas subterráneas estas
pueden arder hasta 80 centímetros de
profundidad y sacarlas evita la
propagación del fuego acá estamos
cavando el suelo para ver que hay
enterrados y todavía hay brasas ardiendo
debajo y tan pronto como haya indicios
de humo los sacamos y los exigimos
poniendo arena sobre estos miles de
bomberos se han movilizado para contener
las llamas unas que han sido
consideradas como las más grandes de la
historia de francia y que han desplazado
a decenas de miles de personas